he 42 here the Roman Colosseum is one of
Earth's greatest monuments to humanity's
long and rugged history from Verona to
Pompeii and even in Africa amphitheaters
were erected by the Roman Empire to
entertain the public in the most
inhumane way possible ferocious beasts
such as lions tigers elephants and birds
would have to fight for their lives
against gladiators who were usually
slaves and criminals sometimes the
animals will be made to fight each other
and of course there were the public
executions a spectacle where criminals
would be tied up like meat under the
rave wild animals would feed upon them
out of these horrors grew a great need
for captured wild beasts and so was born
one of the most dangerous jobs mankind
has ever performed the beast hunters a
group of pioneering entrepreneurs who
risked their lives to hunt down and
capture wild beasts then brought them
back to amphitheaters all over the
empire for use in the games Tigers came
from Amenia elephants giraffes ostriches
leopards and hippos from Africa and
bears came from northern Europe records
show of a man who specialized in the
capture of wild birds whose name was you
serious literally translated as bear
hunter the hunters couldn't use bows or
Spears because of the risk of inflicting
a wound upon the animal that would
become infected and the animal needed to
be in good health ready to fight its
opponent when it arrived in the
amphitheater of course tranquilizer
darts didn't exist back then so these
beat hunters had to be created to catch
their unfortunate prey one popular
method was to dig a large pit in the
ground and stick a wooden stick in the
center of the pit with a dead one on top
of it the hunters would then hide and
patiently wait for a lion or other
beasts to come along and investigate the
bait as soon as the lion jumps into the
pit the hunter would lower a cage from
above trapping it another more obnoxious
method was for several hunters to ride
horses around the animal while banging
on drums
the creature will be confused and would
chase to various horses and would
eventually fall over due to exhaustion
and so it could be safely captured of
course when dealing with such dangerous
predators in close confines that haven't
been sedated accidents did happen and
many a beast hunter lost their lives
trying to catch lions and bears while
transporting them back to Italy surely
workplaces have become more regulated
now since the days of the Roman Empire
deaths must be far less common well you
would think so I'm not certainly true
for most professions except for a few
extremely high risk jobs one of which is
one of the deadliest jobs in the world
today welcome to the treacherous
shipyards of Chittagong
it's a hive of Industry and it generates
massive wealth for a few rich families
but it's also one of the most dangerous
places to earn a living in the world
it's a dark industry called ship
breaking when their time roaming the
siege is over ships from all over the
world's oil tankers cruise ships cargo
ships etc are brought to the very tip of
the bay of bengal to their final resting
place at Chittagong Bangladesh this is
where ships come to die and so do people
ships have a typical lifespan of 25 to
30 years before corrosion takes over and
make maintenance too difficult or too
expensive
now considering each ship cost roughly 1
billion dollars to build and they have
to be replaced every 25 years that makes
it an expensive and very lucrative
business
of course when there's hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of valuable
steel and other metals within the
vessels framework you don't just want to
let it sink to the bottom of the ocean
and slowly degrade so companies are only
ships that have reached the end of their
useful life send the dying vessel off to
a ship breaking yard where it is
painstakingly dismantled entirely by
hand the salvaged Rome
cereals usually hundreds of thousands of
tons of it are then sent back to the
elder of the ship so they can sell it to
all sorts of different construction and
recycling companies making back a
portion of the cost of building the ship
in the first place
and the ship breaking yard is paid for
their services now that's all sounds
very well but the process of dismantling
the vessel so huge and dealing with such
large heavy pieces of metal at great
heights on a daily basis is not only
extremely perilous but often
life-threatening
in fact ship breaking is so darn
dangerous that the whole industry was
banned entirely in the Western world by
the 1980s of course that left a huge gap
in the market a gap worth billions one
country where it still isn't thumbs to
this day came flying into the market and
this became one of the world's largest
players in the ship rating industry
Bangladesh since then over Eastern
countries have bitten off a chunk of the
market such as India China Pakistan and
Turkey today India is the world's
largest ship breaker followed closely by
fungal adesh yet despite the competition
the city of Chittagong in Indonesia is
world famous for its ship breaking yard
but for all the wrong reasons it is one
of the most unregulated and dangerous
ship breaking yards out there along with
the deadly Alang ship breaking yard in
India which also happens to be the
world's largest but why is ship breaking
so unforgivingly dangerous one of the
biggest threats is falling metal huge
metal sheets are constantly breaking off
and tumbling down the side of these
gigantic metal structures many workers
are killed after being hit in their head
or completely crushed by pieces of
falling metal there's also a major risk
of us bestest
led or heavy metal poisoning asbestos in
particular was an extremely common
construction material and
alder vessels and workers commonly
developed fatal counselors and other
illnesses due to the many toxins which
they're exposed to on a daily basis some
ship components are filled with deadly
gases that can escape when dismantled
instantly poisoning or suffocating all
surrounding workers this has happened on
multiple occasions and then there are
the fires and explosions using power
tools and blow torches on a vessel that
likely contains a myriad of flammable
fuels gases and other materials causes
frequent fires and sometimes devastating
explosions and of all that isn't bad
enough many workers are simply killed by
plummeting to their death after taking a
wrong step atop of the vessel and for
risking their lives ship breaking yard
workers are paid a measly $3.00 per day
but the West is not without its perilous
professions one of the deadliest jobs
you can do is lumberjacking also known
as logging America was built by
Lumberjacks they felled the trees that
created the first houses and the first
towns despite all the technology
available to us the humble art of
felling trees is still a commonly
practiced profession especially in North
America and Scandinavia however in a
recent study which reveal that
lumberjack Ingle logging has the most
injuries and fertility x' per 100,000
workers than any other profession except
one but I'll talk about that in a minute
lumberjacking was closely followed by
fishermen loggers are 40 times more
likely to diet work than any other
profession so what makes chopping down a
bunch of trees so damn dangerous well a
good place to start is the 100 meter
plus tall trees that's out plummeting
down right next to you several times per
hour all it takes is the slightest error
in the incision for the tree to fall in
the wrong direction and trees can easily
kick back launching themselves right at
you and bark can split
and splinter which can be deadly 84% of
death in logging are due to falling
trees or rolling logs surprisingly only
16% of deaths are due to machinery yes
when chainsaw accidents do happen
they are often gruesome and fatal this
x-ray of a tree surgeon whose chainsaw
slipped and went into his chest tells a
thousand words what things have
definitely improved from the pioneering
days of the early logging industry
before electricity was widespread
sawmills were powered by steam which
meant they needed a constant supply of
water thus they were often positioned
downriver where out the trees would be
felled further up the river there were
no vehicles up to this job so how did
the transport of extremely heavy and
cumbersome logs to the sawmill take
place so they could be processed into
more manageable planks well send them
floating down the river of course
ingenious yet simple this was known as
log driving but logs would often get
stuck causing a large pile up and so
specialist water runners known as Water
Rats would rapidly hop from one slippery
wet rolling log to another and hunt for
the log causing the job so that they
could free it taut by poking it as you
can imagine fertility zhh were frequent
among these Water Rats the current is
ferociously strong and all it took was
one wrong step to be swept underneath
whilst all of these jobs are inherently
dangerous not more so than is
statistically most dangerous job in the
world with more desperate than any of a
profession on earth what if I told you
that there's a job that has an 18%
fertility rate compared to loggers with
a fertility rate of 0.1 3% and fishermen
with a rate of 0.12 percent that job is
President of the United States
out of the 44 previous presidents eight
have died whilst in office a staggering
fertility rate of 18 percent four of
whom were assassinated meaning nine
percent of US presidents have been
killed whilst in office and some people
spend millions of dollars on dedicate
their lives to achieving this
prestigious yet frightfully dangerous
job proving once and for all that the
bigger they come the harder they fall
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please click here to support
me on patreon which helps me to make
better videos click here to watch
another video and if you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe